de la philosophie à la culture à présent
bonsoir mélanie les victimes pour cela
merci d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
vous êtes chef d'orchestre pour la pms
qu l'association pour la promotion de la
musique à saint quentin en yvelines on
va évoquer avec vous l es journées
musique classique pour tous vous en
assurer la direction artistique ce sera
les 21 et 22 juin au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines benoît hamon
le ministre devrait aussi être présent
le vendredi soir pour une séquence
dédiée exclusivement aux enfants le
grand choeur des enfants des écoles de
50 ans qui va se produire
qui sont ces enfants qui vont monter sur
la scène comme des adultes comme des
professionnels absolument ce sont les
enfants des écoles de trappes de
montigny de la verrière et d'elancourt
donc plusieurs classes par lycée donc
ils sont 370 3 70 pour un choeur amateur
et que j'essaye de professionnaliser au
mieux et ce matin on avait une de nos
dernières répétitions
j'espère qu'il regarde pas trop que
c'était pas mal j'ai tout le temps avec
l'exigence pour toujours qu'ils aillent
bat toujours plus haut toujours plus
d'exigence et pas seulement pour la
musique mais aussi la concentration la
discipline la tenue sur scène et ça
c'est touchant de les voir de plus en
plus sérieux ça très au sérieux à vous
donner avec eux depuis quand alors il ya
des intervenants musique il ya les
instituteurs qui nous aide énormément
bien sûr pour travailler sur les textes
qui font écouter les cd qu'on donne il
ya des intervenants musique qui vont
toutes les semaines dans les classes et
moi j'interviens à partir du mois de
février
l'idée que j'intervienne pas dès le mois
d'octobre c'est pour la montée en
puissance attention le chef arif et
aprilia lors qu est ce qu a ri puis
après on va au théâtre d'essayer de qui
ne se lasse pas parce qu'ils sont
obligés de travailler beaucoup
c'est une endurance étonnante ce qu'on
leur demande
donc voilà on tient cette montée il
arrive à faire la part des choses
justement entre l'école il faut pas
lâcher non plus le travail à l'école il
faut continuer à s'impliquer aussi sur
ce projet est-ce que quelquefois en
route il est difficile de les garder
tous vous en perdez quelques-uns non on
perd personne
c'est une première réussite mais qu'on
doit aussi aux instituteurs qui les font
travailler qui tiennent vraiment à ce
projet et puis se rendent comptent tous
on se rend compte à chaque fois dans ses
projets que pourtant fait de la musique
on fait des maths parce que on compte en
soustrait on additionne on bat la mesure
on respire sur des temps bien défini on
fait du français ou des langues parce
que là c'est en français l'année
dernière on a monté de chiguy dan dans
une langue inventée
ils ont eu envie de traduire cette
langue inventée on leur avait pas du
tout demander ça au travail de
linguistique extraordinaire et le
lendemain la maîtrise de trappes est un
groupe d enfants particulièrement doué
qui s'engagent viennent chanter king
arthur en anglais le lendemain semant
même donc c'est un travail de
mémorisation aussi chantent tous par
coeur important de le dire parce que
c'est quand même une performance des
professionnels et leur instituteur me
dise bas après la récitation la poésie
ça va beaucoup plus vite ses succès en
plus d'y apparaître très facile à côté
un camp l'opéra français voyage c'est le
nom du spectacle du vendredi donc avec
les enfants voyagent entre les oeuvres
de berlioz bizet ou encore offenbach
pouvez nous en dire un petit spectacle
j'ai choisi ce ce programme parce que je
voulais leur montrer qu'au 19e siècle
alors que l'allemagne et la russie se
déverser dans un romantisme exaltant
avec que dans un mois a exacerbé la
france a dit non nous on va pas rentrer
dans ce mélo dramatisme on va décrire le
monde et pour ça ils ont voyagé
donc c'est bien sûr carmen avec
l'espagne c'est les pêcheurs de perles
de bizet aussi avec l'inde
c'est la légende de faust de goethe donc
on les a emmenés en allemagne ils ont
fait des dessins avec faust et méphisto
vu par berlioz est vu par gounod c'est
la pavane de fauré donc c'est paris avec
offenbach donc le cancan la barcarolle
les tubes aussi de d'offenbach
je voulais leur montrer que la france
avait a franchi toutes les frontières
aux 19e et avait remis l'homme au sein
de la nature au sein du monde et ça
c'était une très belle
c'est un très beau courants stylistiques
que la france a montré
ce 19e siècle vous nous l'avez dit les
encore eu des répétitions ce matin il y
en a peut-être encore quelque jusqu'au
dernier moment ça se poursuit julie
rocha suarez pour la rédaction jonathan
wheelman également sont venus pour au
pouvoir pour voir comment se passait
justement les changes avec ses enfants
comment se passaient le contact
reportage
m
des enfants de primaire qui chante de la
musique classique
c'est le pari depuis dix ans d'une
association saint-quentinoise c'est en
les mettant sur scène et en les faisant
chanter ensemble des grands choeurs
d'opéra que il peut vraiment le
découvrir en plus c'est amusant parce
que cette année il ya plein d'opéra très
très connu et il nous a mais ça c'est la
pub at-elle ça c'est la pub à t-elle
cette année douze écoles et près de 400
enfants participent au projet quand
l'opéra français voyagent ils ne sont
pas réticents ils sont curieux réseau
comme étant et puis face il est fasciné
par un chef d'orchestre donc une
personne qui mène à la baguette
finalement plusieurs dizaines d'autres
personnes fasciné par les instruments
donc d'instruments monumentaux donc des
violoncelles qui ne voit pas souvent des
gros tambours et au bout du compte ils
adhèrent ils adhèrent au chant il adhère
à la technique à la manière et puis ça
se fait tout seul
vendredi c'était répétition générale car
depuis l'automne chacun apprend par
coeur les partitions d'opéra du 19e
siècle
je t'aime
si jeanne
et pour certains comme jordan c'est un
plaisir
il a même intégré la maîtrise de trappes
jordain je crois que cet hymne à la vie
d alors en classe aussi c'est attentif
avec bonne concentration bonne mémoire
bien les v campus et leur jolie voix et
la musicalité naturel
si aujourd'hui le petit choristes
chantent berlioz ou carmen quand on me
demande qui est son chanteur préféré
il répond la foule donc c'est du rap
c'est pas du tout du classique
finalement le plus dur pour les enfants
ce n'est pas de s'ouvrir à l'opéra
français
mais la discipline cet outil qui
viennent de se battre on va tous d'ici
et on verra si vous chantez jacobins
avec les trois roses ça c'est pas
possible de ce chant des marais dont
jean croit évidemment
depuis dix ans ce projet attire un
nouveau public
je suis vraiment ravi parce que le
théâtre il est plein de population
toutes les couleurs à la salle est
pleine de gens qui ont jamais mis les
pieds dans le théâtre et année après
année on sent une écoute de plus en plus
forte des populations la première année
ça sifflait ça hurlait comme c'est un
match de foot
maintenant les familles ce sont les
mêmes écoutes comme si elle venait à la
salle pleyel mal on a entendu dans ce
reportage
c'est sérieux on ne rigole pas ou alors
vous attendez on a entendu reprendre un
petit peu remettre decker un petit peu
l'organisation l'ordre meurent en
coulisses
oui c'est pas en coulisses pendant qu'on
chantait il y avait une petite fille qui
s'est mis à tirer les cheveux et abat
frappé un petit garçon ac auteur gilles
ça c'est pas possible à vous battre vous
sortez les anons me chanter trop mal
bataille s'autogère en fait sur la
discipline mais voilà il ya la tension
qui monte aussi avant le spectacle il y
en a qui découvre le trac ça il dit je
commence à avoir peur je pourrais pas
chanter génie tu crois que moi j'ai pas
peur tout le monde a peur et c'est
formidable d'avoir peur et comment vous
les amener à se dépasser justement à
pousser les limites
comment comment vous travaillez avec je
crois que c'est la musique ainsi bizet
berlioz qui demande une exigence et il
entend très facilement quand c'est
mauvais finalement quand ça marche pas
quand c'est pas juste quand il n'y a pas
d'énergie aussi ils le sentent
donc moi j'ai fait beaucoup de travail
sur l'énergie pour moi même parce que
quand on est chef d'orchestre on
travaille là dessus j'ai fait le 15 ans
d'arts martiaux aussi pour trouver
comment ne pas s'épuiser pour ça que ça
ne rigole pas non mais les armes à sion
c'est très souple aussi mais c'est vrai
que cette énergie j'essaye de leur passé
et de leur apprendre quoi parce que ne
serait-ce que rester debout a chanté
pendant ils vont chanter pendant 60
minutes
c'est fatigant c'est fatigant donc voilà
on apprend tout ça aussi finalement ils
sont demandeurs puisque vous nous avez
ramené sur ce créneau l'un des petits
cadeaux qui vous ai fait que je vais
présenter je vais me permettre à la
caméra voilà des d un petit coeur tout
simplement voilà avec son très gentil
qui vous ont écrit c'était trop bien
j'ai aperçu un mois par exemple
après ensuite il continua malheur qui
partit alors valeur revoir ce qui est
extra dire c'est que ce dessin est
arrivé donc avant le concert qui est 21
et 22 juin
mais l'année dernière après tchikidan
j'avais laissé le mon site pour qu'ils
puissent m'écrire j'ai été mais vraiment
comme une star je répondais à monter
courrier le matin et plein m'ont dit
mais on a commencé à l'école de musique
le piano le violon
ça les a encouragé ces enfants là c'est
d'abord notre public de demain et c'est
peut-être nos musiciens de demain et ça
ce serait vraiment formidable
et moi mon rêve c'est aussi que plus
tard ils viennent chanter dans le coeur
des yvelines d'un des grands avec lequel
on fait le lendemain king arthur et je
les invite tous bien sûr à revenir voir
le spectacle est dans la salle ce jour
là donc il aura cette représentation le
vendredi on vous invite forcément venir
découvrir le travail de ses enfants il
faut juste réservé auparavant
puis le lendemain il ya un spectacle
aussi et c'est une partie des enfants
peut être les plus engagés on ne va pas
dire les plus doués aussi qui vont
monter sur scène avec ces professionnels
les adultes absolument c'est ce qu'ils
avaient envie de chanter plus les
parents qui étaient d'accord pour les
amener plus ou c'est le lendemain à 21 à
20h30 également pareil king arthur de
purcell il chante donc en anglais donc
c'est la maîtrise de trappes monté par
gabriela bodart isner et grâce à allah
pms cul et puis ils ont envie de plus
chanter ils chantent bien les parents
les suivent aussi pour ça et j'espère
que cette maîtrise ils sont une
vingtaine ils étaient une dizaine
d'année dernière ba qui sait un jour ils
seront peut-être une centaine sait-on
jamais alors juste pour terminer cette
séquence je vous propose un dernier
micro-trottoir comment développer la
culture pour tous parce que c'est le
travail que vous
également voici vos réponses en
favorisant peut-être plus les choses au
sein des différentes villes et des
petits villages aussi qu'il est chose
qui soit fait de façon plus ponctuelle
organisé dans les écoles ou par les
mairies la rue ça marche bien dans la
rue ça décroche des sourires ça fait ça
fait travailler peut-être créer des
ateliers avec les avec les personnes
âgées
je crois que ça passe très bien les
enfants que les personnes âgées raconte
un livre est bonne émission comme dans
le temps en ouvrant davantage de centres
pour que les jeunes puissent y aller
régulièrement
et puis va mélanger les cultures
justement la ram 1,28 m je pense qu'il
faudrait faire des émissions en prime
time plus souvent concernant la culture
comme c'était le cas avec apostrophe il
ya quelques années
et puis diffuser les
tout ce qui est culturel par internet et
puis le travail aussi des associations
comme la vôtre l'association de
promotion pour la musique à saint
quentin en yvelines la pms q vous venez
régulièrement sur ce plateau
n'hésitez pas à revenir pour nous parler
de vos prochains projets en tout cas
vendredi et samedi 21 22 juin quand
l'opéra français voyagent et puis saxons
les bretons c'est la thématique sur le
lendemain pour découvrir le travail de
ses enfants quasi professionnelle merci
à vous merci beaucoup